je reçois pour débuter cette édition aux
derniers bonsoir ça vous êtes
responsable de la mission handicap pour
l'entreprise sodexo dont le siège est
basé à guyancourt
depuis une quinzaine d'années ce
concours de cuisine est organisé les
réserver aux personnes en situation de
handicap
la finale se déroulait cet après midi on
va en voir d'ailleurs rapidement les
images au cours de cet entretien
cette équipe en finale composée d'une
personne handicapée d'un éducateur d'un
collaborateur de l'établissement vous
prenez l'entr'aide à travers ce concours
en fait tout à fait l'entrée de la
solidarité et le travail en équipe
alors trois personnes qui composent
c'est ses équipes il y en avait sept en
finale qui l'emportait d'où viennent ces
équipes
alors c'est une équipe si je ne me
trompe pas du nord de la france avec un
dessert qui s'appelle l'ubs et à l'ubs
et à puisque deux personnes de l'équipe
s'appelait une personne s'appelle
lucienne et l'autre béatrice c'était un
dessert à base de viol est donc il y
avait des représentants de chacune des
régions c'est ça il y avait il y avait
donc cette région qui était représentée
alors quand je dirige en grande région
française du sud ouest le nord-est de la
france
l'ile-de-france ainsi de suite et donc
cette équipe qui ont concouru tout
l'après-midi sous donc dû réaliser vous
l'avez dit un dessert un indice à ces
personnes sont des personnes handicapées
en personne en situation de handicap
comment se passe justement l'intégration
de ces personnes au quotidien dans
l'entreprise il ya il est un concours
pour favoriser l'entr'aide mais au-delà
de ce qu'on a alors ce sont des
personnes qui ont concouru cette après
midi qui ne sont pas salariés de sodexo
mais résidente dans des établissements
où sodexo intervient comme
prestataire de restauration et
partenaires de ces établissements donc
nous avions des jeunes issus dit m e
institut instituts médico éducatifs des
personnes issues des athées etc et qui
ont concouru avec leurs éducateurs et
avec un une personne de ceux d'exxon
comme vous l'avez au delà de ça
effectivement nous avons toute une
politique handicap chez sodexo pour
l'intégration de cette fois-ci de
salariés en situation de handicap au
sein de notre entreprise tant sur
l'intégration mais aussi sur le maintien
dans l'emploi de salariés qui acquiert
un handicap au cours de la vie suite à
une maladie ou un accident
il est environ 900 personnes en
situation de handicap c'est ça tout à
fait 960 rien de précis 960 personnes
qui travaillent et qui travaille à quel
poste qu'ils occupent
quelles fonctions tout type de fonction
dans l'entreprise alors en grande
majorité des fonctions sur nos sites d
emploi de restauration des cuisiniers
des chefs de cuisine des responsables de
sites mais aussi des personnes de
l'encadrement des responsables régionaux
des contrôleurs de gestion c'est assez
c'est très vaste
le quota légal c'est 6% pour les anciens
dessins plus de 20 salariés
forcément ça concerne sodexo est ce que
vous respectez ce quota de 6% car nous
n'y sommes pas encore nous avons à fin
2012 un taux d'emploi qui est de 4 98%
donc on n'est pas très loin mais je
pense qu'on arrive sur la partie la plus
compliquée à atteindre le
la différence entre 5 et 6 puisqu'il
faut continuer à construire en
permanence dans ce qui est compliqué
justement c'est de trouver des personnes
qui soient qualifiés n'ont pas forcément
parce que vous embauchez aussi les
personnes qui n'ont pas que nous pouvons
recruter à tout niveau de qualification
ce n'est pas tant le fait de trouver des
candidatures qui est compliqué pour
sodexo
c'est déjà d'avoir des postes à pourvoir
des postes à proposer et d'avoir la
bonne adéquation poste personne au bon
endroit avec les bonnes compétences car
ils travaillent ou après a accusé
forcément avec sont pas forcément pas
forcément nous avons aussi des activités
non ce qu on notamment ceux que l'on
appelle pardon le facility management
donc on a des personnes qui sont agents
de courrier peut être agent d'accueil
leur travail aussi en propreté notamment
sur des sites en hospitalier par exemple
et puis des métiers un peu plus vastes
comme des techniciens en maintenance
mais ensuite il est possible de faire
carrière tout à fait nous retournerions
handicap tout à fait même politique
d'accompagnement tourisme en place
effectivement pour tout ce qui est
formation la formation est rendu assez
accessible si les handicaps le
nécessitent par exemple ou tout
simplement un interprète en langue des
signes lorsqu'on est sourd et muet et
qu'on a besoin de poursuivre la
formation comme tout à chacun d'avoir
quelqu'un qui nous traduisent les propos
du formateur on a notamment une
collaboratrice rita qui a récemment
réussi un cqp commis de cuisine cqp
certificat de qualification
professionnelle donc un diplôme reconnu
par la branche professionnelle voulait
former vous les accompagnez ça coûte
cher à l'entreprise
il ya un budget pour ça vous êtes chargé
de la mission handicap tout à fait bien
bouger ce budget il ya un budget qu'il
est dédié à ces actions du fait de notre
accord handicap ça ce sont des
dispositions légales puisque nous avons
signé un accord qui est agréé par le
ministère du travail
ce budget doit être au moins égale à ce
que l'on devrait verser théoriquement un
organisme qui s'appelle l'agefiph
il est aujourd'hui environ 300000 euros
par an d'accord il vous reste encore
éventuellement des postes à pourvoir
parce que vous avez tout à l'heure c'est
de trouver des postes à proposer pour
ces personnes en situation de handicap
est-ce qu'ils existent est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
propositions d'embauché
le plus simple c'est agit sur notre site
internet et les offres y seront ajoutés
bien que je ne peux pas l'icône un steak
alors effectivement ce sera un petit peu
compliqué c'est la question piège de cet
entretien
on en revient à ce concours que vous
organisez déjà cet après midi avec cette
finale
cent quinze équipes au départ c'est ça
elles viennent d'où ces équipes même si
elles sont composées
les gens de francs sont des volontaires
exactement donc une équipe par
établissements volontaires là aussi de
toutes les régions de france dont il ya
eu des finales régionales qui ont permis
de sélectionner au final les sept
équipes qui ont été présentes
aujourd'hui très mélodique c'est pas
forcément des salariés de l'entreprise
sodexo qui alors c'est pourquoi les
personnes handicapées ne sont pas
salariés de l'entreprise sodexo carte
est l'objectif pour sodexo
alors l'objectif passé c'est de pouvoir
justement développé et a mené ses
montées ces personnes en compétences
même si elles intégreront peut-être pas
sodexo un jour mais voilà qu'elle puisse
prendre confiance en elle et son
encontre
certes on est une personne handicapée
mais ça n'empêche pas de réaliser des
choses est de participer à un concours
de cuisine
quels ont été les critères alors les
critères c'est il ya des aspects dans
évidemment d'hygiène respect des normes
d'hygiène les aspects de gond de
présentation comme n'importe quel
concours et puis aussi de faisabilité
ensuite sur les restaurants des recettes
qui ont été proposées et vous avez
découvert des desserts qui vous ont
particulièrement ravi ou non pour les
déguster j'ai pas eu la chance de
déguster celle des membres du jury
pouvait le faire par contre j'ai vu des
desserts qui a l'oeil mais en tout cas
j'ai très envie notamment le dessin
gagnant
il y avait des choses vraiment assez
extraordinaire ne serait ce qu'en termes
de technique c'est la quinzième édition
de cette compétition cette année
ça veut dire que les résultats sont
forcément satisfaisant que sont devenus
les participants des éditions
précédentes
il continua pour la plupart est dans les
établissements où les interviennent
certains concours plusieurs années de
suite et retentent leur chance
est-ce qu'ils intègrent ensuite est ce
qu'ils deviennent salariés au nom de
sodexo ils peuvent s'ils ont les
compétences et la capacité à intégrer ce
qu'on appelle le milieu ordinaire de
travail
c'est arrivé pas à ma connaissance sur
les sur les personnes qui ont réalisé de
concours mais nous avons des grands
régulièrement des personnes issues des
at on un exemple intéressant du côté de
tours l'an dernier à l'occasion
justement ce concours sur ce plateau
nous avions évoqué le troisième accord
handicap de sodexo qui avait été signée
pour la période 2012 2014
et ça on est forcément là au milieu on
peut faire mieux d'un point d'étape et
rappeler en quoi consistait cette accord
handicap pour l'entreprise alors
l'accord handicap prévoit un certain
nombre d'objectifs dans bouche et de
maintien dans l'emploi comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure alors sur l'
embauche pour la première fois nous
n'avons pas tout à fait atteint nos
objectifs nous avions un objectif de 60
embauches on en a fait 58 on y était
presque mais c'est vrai que le contexte
économique n'a pas été favorable pour
nous également puisque si nos clients ne
vont pas bien
forcément ça peut avoir des
répercussions par contre là on est en
est content et satisfait si sur le
maintien dans l'emploi puisque on a un
objectif de 120 tient souvent dans
l'emploi sur trois ans on a déjà réalisé
33 et là sur l'année 2013 ont déjà une
quinzaine de maintien dans l'emploi donc
voilà on est on est assez content et
puis les choses commencent à avancer
sur cette question là les gens
anticipent les managers aussi et on
arrive à de beaux résultats
vous êtes dans les clous sur ce cet
accord handicap voilà à peu près mais
sans faire non plus en restant humble
parce que ça demande beaucoup de travail
merci à vous le concours donc de cette
entraide pour dépasser le handicap qui
vient de se tenir cet après midi à
guyancourt au siège de l'entreprise
sodexo nous en reparlerons dans notre
édition de demain avec un reportage
complet de la rédaction